[Music]
hey guys and Welcome to our Bullet Storm
full clip Edition live stream I have a
special guest today Hutch is here with
me hey how's it going how's it going
guys so this is all brought to you by
our friends at Dell gaming and we're
going to be playing on the Inspiron
157000 laptop we're going to show you
that a bit later but first we're going
to jump right into the game if you're
not familiar Bullet Storm full clip
Edition is the remaster of the original
bullet storm that came out in 201 11 so
what are we doing today in this game so
we're going to go through the uh the
campaign I don't I don't have it on Echo
mode so that's fine we'll just we can
skip through the so if you're not
familiar with the echo mode skips
through all the cutcenes but they might
be fun who knows we'll check them out
and if you got the chance to pre-order
this game then you can also play this
campaign as Duke Nukem which is super
fun I was playing that yesterday and he
has his old different script they got
the original voice actor I could do that
I could switch that here let me switch
that sure yeah do you want to play as
Duke Nukem yeah we'll check it out I
think everyone wants to see Duke Nukem
we're also over in chat so we're
streaming in three different places
right now well actually Four technically
on Gamespot gamespot's YouTube
gamespot's twitch and hello to everyone
on Twitch uh on Hut's Channel my chat I
see you right here I got you up on my
phone uh so how do I pick Duke is it
this one here oh there it is Duke nuk's
tour there you go Hail to the King baby
and it may contain Mater that's fine
they know what they're in for all right
so we're load this up here we're going
to go to sel all right so basically it's
Duke nukem's just replacing the main
character from the original game and
they gave him a whole new script so
that's what you're in for now so this
was made by Cliffy B and his team right
wasn't this uh un
un epic epic games that's what it was
right I I think so yeah but um putting
you on the spot here I don't remember
I'm so sorry I didn't play the original
did are we professionals or not we are
professionals I did not play the
original I did not play the original
yeah I've only played full clip Edition
which is just a remaster of the original
so I guess technically we played the
original for a bit okay this week yeah
technically I did play the original just
this
morning and yesterday what's up with
this laptop here what what am I working
with yeah you're working with the
Inspiron 157000 which is one of Dell's
gaming laptops and it's a 15in and it's
got quite a few features we're going to
jump into that later when we show off
the b-roll but just to let you know it
does have a nice sturdy redesigned hinge
for a stronger closing motion it has has
an improved keyboard with testing for
keys for 10 million keystrokes and
touchpad buttons and it's got a dual fan
cooling system GTX 1050 and a whole
bunch of other things and I'll tell you
about that later you'd expect it to be
louder yeah no expect it to be like
pretty quiet which is nice doubl
after
This Guy's in trouble I can't skip this
one that's fine I don't know if it's
supposed to be like this with like the
double but I think so worth twice
that I actually played with no cut scen
the first time around see you in hell no
hey hey hey what the [__] man I told you
everything yeah but you tried to kill us
I was thinking about it as I was playing
this earlier this this game feels like
um like sort of like Lincoln Logs of Mer
of of murder is the way that I would
describe it kind of like Minecraft of
murder the Lincoln Logs of murder really
good way to describe I feel like the
whole point of the game is to try to uh
kill people in the most creative ways
possible yes that's basically what
that's the whole point of the game so if
you are new to this game they give you
lots of points for just killing people
in creative ways which I found super fun
like I kicked a dude into a cactus
yesterday and got bonus points for that
I kicked a Dude down a hole it was a lot
of fun and they like freezes and then
you kick them again and they go flying
yeah get stuck in a gate it's very
satisfying once we get the leash it'll
take like maybe 5 10 minutes to get that
and then we'll show you guys what I'm
talking about yep so we're over in chat
so join us hang out with us we are I'm
reading the chat from games spots
YouTube and twitch if you want to ask
Hutch anything if you want to ask me
anything talk about Bullet Storm tell us
your favorite memories about playing
Bullet Storm and we're also over in
Hutch's chat too indeed so we'll check
in once in Rowdy bunch in my chat but
but they mean well that's
good damn I feel like you would die
instantly in that spot I don't think you
would survive but then again we're Duke
in your G so I think we're okay we can
suspend disbelief
to yeah they just walk it off
yeah over in chat um on YouTube Ben said
Bullet Storm is basically Tony Hawk with
guns yeah that's a good that's a perfect
way to describe it to that is a great
description Ben thanks your mom survived
crappy assassin on you Youtube said this
is one of my favorite games I can see
why I'm new to it and it was so much fun
I was like laughing the entire time I
was playing this yesterday I don't know
what that says about me but it was a
good
[Music]
time um maybe we can yeah that's all
right all right and we're ready let's
jump in I need to tell you you need to
crouch here what other games are you
playing these days I'm playing Persona 5
like crazy right now and right before
that I was playing breath of the wild
how about you um I've been playing a
bunch of uh Modern Warfare remaster
rocket League chess uh I wanted to get
into Horizon zero Dawn but I just have
not had the time I haven't had time I
haven't had time like I was playing
Zelda and I just kind of skipped over it
and then before that I had to uh play
some games for work so I just didn't
have time what games did you have to
play for work um I was playing for Honor
for work I was
playing
I had to play Mass Effect also and so I
just never had time between all that and
also Zelda just took up all of my free
time until Persona came up do you find
that working in the industry you do do
you get to still play games for yourself
oh you do yeah I'm not working on any
features for Persona 5 I'm just doing
that for me oh that's good cuz I love
Persona I'll try to stop saying persona
but I've not I've not played that I
don't know if that's sa but
oops someone over on YouTube said Hut
works for GameSpot no no he's just here
today as a special guest he's just
joining me to hang out and play Bullet
Storm I'm a temporary employee of the
day just for the
day when did did they just add the um oh
I can skip this did they just add Duke
Nukem for this part for the whole for
the uh I'm sorry for the uh no but for
for the Edition
yes and it's only for those who
pre-ordered it so sorry if you missed
out but now you get to watch it with us
this part is not easy
oh my gosh there we
go
wow cool yeah is if you've played the
original and you're looking at this new
Full Clip Edition now let us know in the
chat if you think it looks better we did
a graphics comparison and it I think it
looks a little bit better than the
original but I didn't really play the
original so I don't know if I'm fairly
comparing when all I saw was
so if you think that there are
improvements in the game let us know and
I'll be reading those in the chat did I
just oh
je okay no we're good we're
good uh favorite movie from outer space
Oh my God aliens aliens yeah I would say
alien over aliens I like I like the
action movie but yeah no it's because
I'm terrified of alien and I can't I
can't watch it oh it's great time but it
is great it is fantastic
I I feel like I'm one of the few people
out there that actually enjoyed
Prometheus but that's just me getou are
you psyched for alien isol I'm super
psyched yeah I I I thought the trailer
was terrific yeah uh I saw life recently
covant alien Covenant that's what it is
yeah uh did you see the trailer to that
that Jake gyen yeah it came out already
I didn't see it but it looked kind of
cliche was it bad saw it okay was it
cliche yeah you've seen that movie there
was a paint by numbers trailer and it's
like oh no we found something oh it's
bad for us oh it's going to kill us all
yeah you basically saw everything in the
trailer anyway so seems pretty
predictable yeah a few years
earlier Sunshine that's another good one
Sunshine is fantastic real great I love
that movie The Third x gets a little
bananas but it's kind of crazy I still
appreciate the third Act is so it's way
different from the rest of the movie but
I I love the entire thing I think it
comes together okay take no joy in
killing We Are Soldiers I mean I guess
we could talk about Star Wars too yeah
yeah that new Star Wars trailer just
dropped today and I didn't know how I
was going to be able to focus you seemed
pretty emotional I was very emotional
when I ran into you and I think you had
just watched it yeah when I first saw
you when you came in this morning I was
like God there is a new Star Wars
trailer did you see it yet you're like
no not yet I'm just like watch it yeah
that was the that was the first time
well I met you technically at a work
party but but within 5 Seconds hey did
you see the star yeah that's how I said
hello oh hi how are you did you see the
new Star Wars I nearly freaking cried
during during uh episode seven just cuz
I was so yeah nostalgic and worked out
so I'm really looking forward to it just
bring up all those feelings of when
you're watching the original Star Wars
Trilogy as a child and then getting to
see that world come together again did
you dig uh Rogue one that's a pretty
divisive divisive movie I did like it
actually I like Rogue one
yeah so did I yeah I'll admit that maybe
the First Act was very slow but the
third act more than makes up for it oh
the beach scene is great like the
visuals in that movie is
incredible the you calling me for no not
this part all right so now we've got
Duke Nukem here leading the team shut
the [__] up I'm not even supposed to be
just tuning in we're playing pet storm
full clip Edition you asked me to turn
off the swearing and
then mother think you were going out
there all this time how does one truly
censor
watch go ahead kill them
all we'll just you guys shooting I can't
tell on YouTube Someone said I thought
this game was coming to the Nintendo
skip now this is for the PS4 Xbox One
and PC only and it came out last week
one week ago on the
seventh and this is a remaster of the
original Bullet Storm from 2011 and that
originally came out for PS3 Xbox 360 and
PC uh and I'm pretty sure this was made
by uh EP epic in in uh it gearx gearx
yeah let I think the guys at Epic Games
Cliffy cliffy's team made this right
after he he left um GE of work could be
wrong on that don't quote me
in fact I'm almost certain wrong I think
it's a different team that did the
remaster
okay so what's uh what's Persona 5 can
you Persona 5 is fun it's a jrpg it's
the fifth in the series well I don't
know unless you can't dancing all night
but it's it's a lot of fun you go
through castles it's it's very anime but
it's uh it's good I like it a lot having
a lot of fun with it but basically
you're a high school student from um
you're transer because you got into some
trouble and then kind of get caught up
in this world Between Worlds type of
thing and then like where your school is
not really a school sometimes it's I
won't I won't spoil it but it's fun it's
fun you should play
it I that that's one genre I never got
into as a kid was was the RPG genre and
then have you played any final
fantasies no uhuh like the first RPG
that I think that I play would probably
be like Mass Effect one if you want to
count that um and yeah that's that's I'm
I'm into it now yeah I dig Skyrim but I
just never played any of the jrpgs got
it yeah what am I what am I doing here
hello all right we're good your team
some dude's knocked out on his
shoulder there we go yeah he just use it
it's it that thing's hanging by a
thread so yeah this game is all about
like creative kills yeah so there's a
mechanic that we'll get to in about
maybe 5 10 minutes where you get this
kind of electric leash yeah and you can
pull things towards you that yeah you
you pull people's guns towards you you
can do it to need up open things and
like there's like this thing that you
can get all sort of gear out
ofat onto so they got a few different
mechanics here you got a slide do that
the energy leash there and you got the
slide here and then you got a kick
that's pretty much it is super
fun out of him for if you got any
questions for Hut let us know over on
YouTube and twitch get those answer for
you let's check in the chat will it's
done by people can fly used to be owned
by epic got it thank just keep them
alive be right
back you may take my freedom uh but you
shall never take my safe in space
what other games do you think should be
remastered so many um I mean I'm really
hoping they remaster Modern Warfare 2
this year I wasn't a big fan of it when
it came out but uh I think I'd have a
lot of fun with it now yeah
you over on YouTube fire bucket said
Dead Space remaster yep I never played
that
[Music]
game so I think we get our leash here in
a second oh that'll be fun own so that's
the kind of stuff that we were talking
about where it'll give you stuff in the
environment that you can kick them into
or throw at them or
whatever uh and It's oddly um
therapeutic like you just you just you
just kind of get lost and zone out yeah
so I think our goal for this stream is
just to see how creative we can get with
the kills was that not supposed to go
down here Noe all right ouch on fire
seems bad over here seems like a bad
time okay yeah fire in space no buo
nobody likes
that
well nice I love the kick we just go
flying the uh so the sensitivity feels a
little bit funny cuz you can uh so you
see you can change your sensitivity but
it doesn't change the ads sensity so
even though this is kind of slow as soon
as I zoom zoom in it
faster world and
then is over here
somewhere uh in a second it'll unlock
some challenges there we go nice she
blind that energy cell how do you think
that you would Faire in a dystopian
future cuz I think about that question
yeah let's let's think about this so I
think I would I would lay low I'd hide
um I I might be aone wolf in that
situation or I might maybe team up with
like someone that I can really trust but
I pretty much lay low and just like kind
of loot things and speak to myself and
avoid any kind of interactions with
anything um I would always be armed okay
how Adept are you at hand toand combat
I'm okay really but not not great but I
I'm kind of Scrappy how hard could it be
right I'm it depends on who I'm up
against I I think if I'm sneak attacking
someone I can take them out but like if
I'm just like face to face against
someone it's a whole other story and I
don't think I would Faire very well
unless they were like smaller than me or
weaker than me yeah but I'm I'm fast so
there's that if they're like really big
I can get around them or like through
the legs or sweep them yeah if you were
wandering around the desert Wasteland of
the future and you ran into a pack of
like you children you could probably
take like a group of five of them maybe
I don't know that's a lot of kids versus
me and they're they're quicker than me
they're like tiny they'll just crawl on
things like that sounds terrifying
actually I feel totally confident that I
could take on like 10 8-year-olds I
think I could I think I could take
them so what would what role would you
play in The Apocalypse what would you
what was your goal what would you do I
might be a little overconfident here but
I think I would fare really well cuz cuz
I think I'd be able to make those hard
decision what do you do for food you're
hunting you're Gathering both um fishing
I I think I would be I think I would be
a bad guy I really would just just Loot
and pillage everything I can and yeah
that sort of thing that's why I think I
would be good at the apoc survive it's
just like the morals kind of just all
right so we got our leash got our leash
all right we have our energy leash there
we go so that's a rope of energy
projected from a device on your left
hand and the leash allows you to pull
enemies you activate certain devices and
traps slam down a ball of energy that
launches nearby energies enemies into
the
air it's a very cool
tool um yeah and you kind of use it to
get stuff out of out of your way like
that someone on YouTube said they won't
survive the first week I would just hide
so I would survive the first week cuz I
would have no confrontations I might die
the second week or the first time I try
to like confront someone but I if I'm
just hiding I think I would
survive someone said Mad Max in space
yeah pretty much that's what that's
looking
like did it did it tell us what planet
we're on
oh nice yes and
then with a
whip with the whip I think there's
someone else yeah come here showy
yourself
there so now we have to collapse the
barrier you did it yep yep we good
good that LE is so useful so what's
going on with the uh the specs on this
laptop here what kind of processor what
kind of yeah we've got quite a few specs
here uh it's got the GTX 1050 TI is what
this laptop in particular has but
there's different ranges it all starts
at $799 you can scale up depending on
whatever level of additional components
or or performance improvements you'd
like but yeah you can get the GTX 1050
or 1050 TI G
options is it 1050 is that like right
below the 10 1070 or
1060 I was using the alien wear 13 and
like that one had the
106 someone said I love this game
originally yeah I didn't get to
experience this back in 2011 so I'm glad
I'm getting to play it now with the
remaster oh there fun stuff I was
messing around with this last night
trying to prep a little bit and
um sometimes when you agree to do
sponsored stuff you play the game and
it's like okay well I'll make I'll make
do the best I can fun other times it
works out and ends up being fun game
yeah many folks do this
for we going again we need to take that
thing back to the guy yeah fire bucket
said whip it good yeah with the with the
energy a song once said whip it good yes
it did it sure
did what are your favorite Shooters of
the last couple years
neur um I got really into Destiny when
it first came out for super hyped yeah I
couldn't I reached a point where it's
like at during the last DLC probably
where just kind of was like I can't do
this anymore but um yeah really looking
forward to that one
um I play a lot of cod I play a lot of
Modern Warfare remastered right now I
didn't play too much infinite Warfare uh
what did you think of it it was okay you
know like it's just it just wasn't
really wasn't really for me at the time
yeah um gotta what about you did you got
to do it at all or no no I didn't play
that at all actually um I played a lot
at the end of last year I played a lot
of killing 4or I which I that's the uh
the zombie game right okay super
fun um I didn't I didn't play that too
much I didn't play that at all actually
but that's the one where uh it's you can
there's there's like an upgrade system
too right mhm yeah it's like a and they
added a new map recently and some new
guns a new Z it's a lot of fun um but
you work together as a team with
everyone um increasing difficulty and
then they have the different classes and
different um
actually I liked playing support a lot
just to help people out it's always good
to help your friends out did you do you
you prefer co-op games over over uh you
do yeah I like playing co-op
on yeah Co-op wasn't something I got
into
until way later on in my gaming career
but I've come to appreciate it more as I
get older in my it's fun and like when
you play with your your friends it's a
lot of
fun you play any
OverWatch um yeah I played it a little
bit but I just wasn't very good at it
that's a tough I'm okay at it it's tough
I'm okay at it which character did you
play um it depends on what role is
needed on the team I always like try to
yeah but if I'm playing support I'm
playing Mercy and Lucio and then um if I
they need a tank I play Reinhardt and I
play May sometimes and I play Soldier
sometimes
change it up what was the um there was
another game like OverWatch that not
blizzard but uh oh I know what you're
talking about you know what I'm talking
about I I didn't play that
game it kind of came and went gone yeah
battleborn I think it was yes that's the
one that is the one you don't see too
many people talking about that anymore
yeah oh maybe I should have backed off a
little bit
before Andrew on YouTube said Hutch he
said hi what up fire bucket said just
got Dead Rising it is so difficult that
looks like a lot of fun I haven't played
Dead Rising and I really want to Dead
Rising is super fun yeah that's an
pretty similar like use anything and
everything type of deal definitely very
creative
kills kaboom
baby and yes if you are just tuning in
this is the remaster not the original
this is the remaster of Bullet Storm
Bullet Storm full clip Edition and we
are hanging out on YouTube and twitch
taking your questions talking to you in
the chat talking about shooters tell us
what your favorite Sho are what you're
playing right
now get you uh what was your top three
favorite movies last year oh man arrival
is on there did you see it arrival was
my number two arrival is fantastic it
was great um got any IDE I don't know if
Rogue one is in top three but it's
definitely top five for
me it depends on how I feel and also a
10 Cloverfield Lane it was good yeah
real good I that kind of surprised me by
how much I like that movie what a weird
way to do a sequel to that movie too
it's just the same universe yeah pretty
much they're coming out with another one
this year actually yeah how about you uh
my top three was Manchester by the sea I
didn't see it oh yeah I didn't see it
it's brutal man yeah I need to be in the
right mood for those kind of movies like
I like the year before I kept meaning to
watch Spotlight and never did because I
just wasn't in the mood for that yeah
Spotlight is pretty great too yeah it's
it's real good so yeah manest by the
city arrival and then attack um I had a
few I had them all written down I had
there were a lot of good movies that
came out last year yeah there were there
were 2015 was pretty tough to beat but
um this is a good year too there's a lot
coming out this year is there are there
any movies you're looking forward to oh
man that Thor trailer was incredible
that was it's so fun Thor Ragnarok looks
a lot like Guardians of the Galaxy like
they totally changed the tone of the
Thor movies but I'm down with it I think
everyone's feeling that they um they
they hired the guy who's really funny uh
funny director I can't remember his name
it's like ta taiku watti I don't know
how to say his name but he directed what
we do in the shadows he directed I think
eagle versus Shark he's done a lot of uh
some of the Flight of the Concord he
like worked with the guys from Flight of
the Concords yeah um that's such a funny
trailer it'll be a pretty fun movie what
am I doing again here am I going over
here um well that's going to lift did
you take care of everyone on the other
side I think so yeah there here we
go yeah Thor looked great um Wonder
Woman looks great too oh someone
mentioned Green Room I did watch that
last year that Green Room Green Room
fantastic good that's that's a sleeper
that's a sleeper movie for sure yes yeah
I didn't watch that till I rented it on
Amazon this year and I was like this is
a good movie yeah horror is not my genre
and that movie was great yeah that was
more like suspenseful with some gore I
thought it was terrifying it it was
terrifying yeah but yeah Green Room is
definitely one to watch that movie
reminded me of pastel which I love those
movies I don't know if yeah past's great
I don't if you watched those yet uh no I
was too chicken back in the day it's
yeah well it's it's they don't make it
easy to stomach it but it's fantastic
it's super campy it's not to be taken
seriously but Eli Roth right yeah you'll
have a good time I do remember watching
Eli Roth's uh Cabin Fever you have you
seen that that was also that was also
campy and I was like what am I watching
like the part with the
pancakes did you see um Cabin in the
Woods yes I love Cabin in the Woods did
just Sweden direct that or did he WR no
Drew G directed it yeah but I think Jos
Sweden was a part of a producer on it I
believe um yeah no yeah on YouTube
Someone said nocturnal animals was also
good they also said 10 Clover Field Lane
I didn't see nocturnal animals but
agreed on 10 Clover Field Lane nocturnal
animals is another one that's brutal so
like if you watch it you need to make
sure you're in a mood where you feel
like you can endure that's that's the
tough one being in the right mood for
those movies yeah it's real good though
Jake J was great yeah yeah did you uh um
what was that movie he was crawler yeah
he was good in that oh man was great
yeah uh do I need to use these I can use
them so here you can
do yes yeah there we go so we'll use you
can upgrade your capacity byy ammo Clips
so this is is where
you you have to look for those drop kits
around but they have them pretty
commonly like one in each area I think
so I'm not being as creative as I can be
with these kills so I in this area I
just went and kicked everyone like over
and over
again um but I think there's stuff in
the environment that you can use yeah ah
all right people over in the YouTube
chat saying hi hello everybody how you
guys doing if you're just tuning in
thanks for hanging out with us we're
playing Bullet Storm full clip Edition
and we're playing thanks to our friends
over at Dell gaming on the Inspiron
laptop this is a real Sleek laptop by
the way not to be total
sell I like it I was playing on it
yesterday I like it a
lot uh a lot of the times the gaming
laptops they're huge and they're loud
right and they get real hot but this is
we've been playing on this for a little
bit it's not too hot yet yeah you've
been using it all
morning where am I getting hit from oh
Liz James said Thor was in C in the
woods yeah he was oh he was great in
that too he was very good in that that
was a movie I didn't like the first time
I watched it it was really yeah it was
it was way too weird for me espe
especially the end soour Weaver is great
in there too yeah no spoilers if you
haven't seen it you have to see it oh
yeah it's fantastic yeah so good it got
way better than the second time I
watched it for
sure forgive my lack of
nostalgia yeah so they gave Duke Nukem
like a brand new script for the REM so
all these lines are not just rehashed
from the original character which is fun
and they got the original voice actor
for that too only way out is down close
nuk man Duke Nukem dude they wanted to
bring that back for so
long and then when they did it just you
remember when they brought that back it
was not good I didn't play it yeah you
didn't miss out on
yeah let's know if you guys have any
questions over on YouTube and twitch I'm
monitoring the Gamespot YouTube and
twitch and Hutch has his chat up which
he will checking on once in a while I'm
looking down at you little troublemakers
there I'm not saying too much cuz I'm
trying to focus on this yeah
totally oh you have to hit the to use
that thing yeah and then it'll go down
there it
is so were you uh born and raised in the
area no I'm actually from New York how
about you uh yeah was about an hour
north and uh it's now counties where I
yeah so when did you come to the to the
West Coast um I think 2005 so I've been
here for a bit I feel like I'm from now
California's awesome FOC pretty great
yeah there's a song I can't remember the
name of the song but uh it goes uh is it
about California well there's a line in
it about California where it says you
should live in San San Francisco at
least once in your life but leave before
it makes you too soft and then you
should live it in New York at least once
in your life but leave before it makes
you too hard the I agree with that and
I've done I've done both yeah New York
is a lot of fun yeah it is a lot of fun
good food in both cities too those are
both incredible Food Cities the bars in
New York are incredible and they're open
forever yeah until 4 in
morning or on YouTube they said who's
excited for alien Covenant though pretty
excited that trailer was pretty excited
the scene where he's banging head on the
front of that ship just made me go
nuts yeah I think the first time I saw
that trailer was in the theater so that
was an even better experience yeah you
can't watch trailers anymore without
giving giving the movie away yeah they
really do give way too much away Star
Wars did this teaser did a good job you
know like I'm sure I'm sure someone's
going to go through it over with a fine
tooth com yes I'm sure reddit's at it
already but um also we are doing a
breakdown of it on gam SWAT universe so
keep it locked for that on that channel
they're out there just I can hear them
talking and I really want to be part of
it but they just like keep talking about
Star
Wars now they did it with Spider-Man
like the first trailer for Spider-Man
was was pretty good the second home yeah
the teaser and then the First full trail
trailer came out I was like I'd rather
not see all that okay but that's okay I
still don't know too much and the second
trailer came out and you just I feel
like I watched the entire movie it
really bothers me that they do that now
yeah yeah it sucks I just want to see
Spider-Man and Iron Man hanging out
being buddies saving the world together
that's all I want you want to see no in
that movie that's all I want from that
movie okay like I have I have really no
interest in the new villain and what's
going on there I'm sure it's going to be
good I'm sure it's good yeah like I have
complete trust in Marvel
Studios how was the last has there been
a bad Marvel Studios movie yet ah
uh depends on how you feel about certain
sequels like I wasn't the biggest fan of
uh two and three were okay I wasn't the
biggest fan of Captain America 1 the
first time I saw America one is okay
yeah I grew on me over time weer ones
but if you just think of them as comic
movies they still pretty good yeah well
definitely grow on me over time cuz now
if I watch it now I enjoy it
but all right where are we going
now not sure oh wait behind you door
just
open oh y you have to shoot that down no
I think you do it oh
yeah try it again yeah I shot that thing
down and then I opened the thing behind
it by the door yeah this is what you
do there's something else that oh there
it
is looks right up
your provided we hurry is on the other a
lot of people didn't like the second
Thor movie yeah that's true it was it's
forgettable I I enjoyed it but I think
it is forgettable and I wouldn't rewatch
it willingly I think like if it was on
TV and I wasn't doing anything sure but
he's got a real good comedic timing yeah
Chris H yeah he's he's really funny in
the first
one
hello those people talk about du nuk in
the chat right now this is Duke Nukem is
just taking the place of the main
character in The Campaign here so this
is just um if you pre-order the game
full clip Edition then you get to play
the campaign as duke N I was hoping to
yeah it
happens back at
it all right let's
see so I think this is as far as I got
this morning in this game I got a little
bit farther I think yeah um
anyway we are on YouTube and twitch
right now taking your comments and
questions so let us know what you want
to talk about you want to talk about
your favorite Shooters what you're
playing right now or if you have any
memories of the original Bullet Storm
let us know let's hang out hurry crash
site is on the other side of that City
how did you get into the uh uh games
industry uh I started at IGN but um I
had a
small stint helping with a show for ref
three games um are you familiar with
revision 3 at all yeah can you tell me
remind me what games they they've put
out I've heard that studio oh no it was
the studio it was a it was a also a a
channel a YouTube channel that that did
gaming but uh back in 2013 um Adam
cesler was running it and then I was
working with my buddy SC Scott brownley
on a show there and then um after that I
stayed with Discovery and then um some
of my buddies from Discovery went to and
moved on to IGN moved over there and now
I'm here at GameSpot
nice yeah did you think you were going
to be in this industry no uh I actually
initially started in local news did you
yeah for like four years really yeah um
that's where I started and I I studied
TV um TV broadcasting in college and so
I was doing that I interned for Jimmy
Fallon I did some news internships and
then I ended up working in news for like
a couple years is he pretty crazy or is
he's super nice he's like a really nice
boss like one of the nicest bosses
bosses you can ever have he like took
time to learn all the entr names I don't
know if that was because it was his
first year on the job but he was really
nice and I had no idea he knew who I was
but then like on my last day I was like
I'm going to go talk to him just say hey
sorry it's my last day and he's like a
chass you're leaving I'm like you know
who I
am that's good it's a good day yeah and
that's in New York yeah that was in New
York
oh
God Full Throttle gag reflex did you
ever mess up on air when you were doing
the news um I wasn't really an on camera
person when I did uh stuff on the news
like on camera it was all to tape so
it's all edited I was never a live
anchor or anything like that I couldn't
do live TV that'd be too stressful like
this is okay it's a little different
live TV amazing good stuff here just
found my gr final Echo someone said I
remember Bill and Ted bro are you guys
talking about Bill and Ted in the have
you seen phenomenal movie phenomenal I
think they're bringing it back actually
they've been talking about the sequ
couple years that there was talk about
that I firmly believe that movie is
really underrated yes I think a lot of
people think it's just a stupid movie on
no it's a lot of fun that's great all
right so we'll get this charge Nicholas
on YouTube said I like Thor one and two
I I liked him also I I especially like
Thor one though Thor two was all right
yeah I'm going agree with you on that
one Thor Thor one was better than Thor
two but it's uh thor2 wasn't terrible at
all visually it's it's gorgeous it's
really stunning to look
at all
right they caught me sleeping on that
one that's okay we were
distracted last train from explosion
town so we playing the campaign right
now in Bullet Storm full clip Edition as
Duke Nukem cuz that's what you can do if
you pre-order the game but you can play
this on PS4 Xbox One or PC we're playing
it on PC on the Dell Inspiron
157,000 wait did I so do I need to buy
the charge
again yes you have enough yeah
sweet um D you always play a lot of
games uh yeah I mostly focused on
fighting
games for most of my life but yeah when
I was a kid I had the NES and then the
Sega Genesis then I had uh
N64 PS1 PS2 PS3 hand on Xbox U but I
played a lot of fighting games a lot of
Platformers
whoa I just kick them yes kick them
trying to kick them off the side so
satisfying there he goes goodbye thank
you g so one of the things that I didn't
show you guys before is like you get a
series of challenges that you unlock mhm
and then it gives you extra there's a
list right yeah it gives you bonus
points oh God and um can you FP list in
the menu does it show you well I think
you have to do it at the at those little
kiosks oh right right right yeah son of
a dick they got more we've got more
bullets take cover
boys and then it yeah it shows that you
did your objective to kill them in a
creative way up in the top left you
can't get too creative with this chain
onun point and shoot that's pretty much
itpp all used
up so at the next checkpoint or the uh
drop box or whatever it is should be
yeah we can look up those creative kills
that we can
get just stay
close
Oh by verigo 250 well I think I just
kicked him out of the spikes here yeah
not
yes um 250 Points
each go sweet
did you like Mad Max oh man yeah that
that was my favorite movie of uh of uh
2015 agreed that was the best movie of
2015 I lost my mind when I saw in
theaters I yeah I lost my mind oh my God
that was an experience and like with
that movie it's just edge of your seat
the entire time stop it doesn't allow
you to breathe at all and like that was
my only complaint it's like I can't
breathe at all this entire movie
experience I think that's a good thing
by the time got to the end just a mild
spoiler when when when Max suggests that
they turn around and go back I was like
man are they about to cut it off and
then do a Tob continued cuz I was like
there's no way they're going to do
another action set piece and then and
they did yeah and it's like 30 minutes
long back to back oh man it's incredible
it's nonstop that mov is Relentless some
people do not like it and they get
pissed off at people that really that
movie that's great though the soundtrack
is just mhm everything about it so good
I actually get to see Han Zimmer play at
uh what at Coachella to that going that
I'm going um oh there was a concert with
Han Zimmer I think at SF well I'm going
to Coachella in a in a couple weeks he's
playing there that's awesome
so yeah I'm really excited about that
one what's he going to play do you know
I don't know hopefully everything all
right so here those here are those
challenges here so some of them are kind
of funny take a look so we've checked
off a couple actually we checked off
Kill An Enemy by flinging them into a
sharp metal object send an enemy down a
huge drop there's one that's like shoot
him in the nuts and then where is it
yeah kill kill an enemy by shooting him
in the
ass uh slide an enemy and shoot him to
death midair shoot an enemy in the balls
and kick or shoot his head off shoot and
run enemies the legs to trip oh shoot
him in the legs to trip him is one of
them you can you can kick their heads
off I didn't even realize that
come
here all right so this one you can kick
him into the
yeah someone on YouTube I think Wade is
asking is Hutch a new gam SWOT member or
what no he's just here for the day
taking part in this live stream for
Bullet Storm just hanging out I was just
walking down on Market stre yeah I was
like hey dude you want to come play a
video game and he's just like who are
you I'm like you'll have to know and
you're going to pay me to do
this it's like hey you aren't you on
YouTube do you like video games boy we
got one for you to
play great glad to hear it so you can
switch between weapons do you still have
that big
gun um no the the the Gatling gun you
have to put down when you're when you
run out of the club
got
something that has these quick time
events
mhm oh there we
go get
him
out how many kicks does it
take where do you fall on the uh
pineapple pizza debate oh my God we
talked about this on the last stream
yeah last week uh I was Pro pineapple
and Greg was anti- pineapple yeah I'm
firmly anti- pineapple that's okay
that's okay like I get it like when I
think Pizza pineapple is not one of the
first things that I think should be on
there absolutely not but that's your
common sense kicking in I do like
Hawaiian pizza though I don't know if
that's just cuz I'm Filipino but it is
what it is I think it's delicious and I
will not apologize to anyone for eating
it and if there's a party with a bunch
of different pizzas and there's a
Hawaiian one left more for me there it
is Filipinos have some good food man I
just I've just eaten adobo for the first
time this year so good though oh bad for
you I just like the sauce it's in it's
like when you put it in the fridge and
you're like wow that's the sauce that I
was eating oh man that solidified into
some kind of scary congealed lard but
okay you guys are huge fans of uh Ginger
yes I've noticed and uh garlic garlic
everything yes mhm yeah lots garlic I
got into cooking this year Blue Apron so
it's kind of like amateur status forever
but uh yeah it's cooking that's a good
way to start cooking I I that that
service taught me out of cook basically
I didn't know anything about it before
nice
yeah do you use any of those Food
Services I don't I I uh just sometimes
get my groceries delivered sometimes go
on my own but I cook you already know
knew how to cook yeah I can cook my mom
was a really good cook my dad's a pretty
good cook but I'm I'm okay I make
whatever's easy how do I miss
that what is
happening let take cover for a bit it'll
be F it'll be fine yeah so you're good
you're
fine head shot head shot that Bo I'm
trying
trying oh
jeez oh there's a pineapple debate you
just started a war in the chat now we
have one vote anti- pineapple another
vote he says nothing without
pineapple it's a divided chat oh here we
go keeps happening there we go very nice
I pick this up can you gun battery fully
deed
cool we're going to go up here hey sexy
come here oh hey got some weight on
there go nice um artichokes on Pizza has
got to be my favorite really yeah I
don't think I've ever had that oh no I
have there's a place called artichoke
pizza and that's where I've had
it in Berkeley I tried that um garlic
artichoke olives mushrooms wow linguisa
that's creative not really feel like
that's a standard isn't it garlic and
artichokes and linguisa know that that's
pretty not standard dude I just assumed
it was I just pick everything that I
think is delicious and just put it on
there that's smart that's
smart on the big all
right while we're at this cut scene
we're halfway through our stream so
we're going to cut to some b-roll we've
been playing on the Inspiron 157000 so
let's take this some be there it is look
at that beautiful laptop uh we've been
playing on the Inspiron 157,000 it's a
15-inch laptop ideal for gaming and it
features a redesign hinge for stronger
sturdier open and closing motion to
ensure that they still feel tight even
after opening and closing the lid like
20,000 times it would still work
improved keyboard with testing for keys
for to 10 million keystrokes and
touchpad buttons 1 million times with no
failure new dual cool fan wait dual fan
cooling system featuring oversized fans
with rear exhaust to ensure optimal
temperatures even the copper fins are
painted to match the rest of the trim
really nice GTX 1050 as I mentioned and
1050 TI GPU options offer some of the
most impressive performance per dollar
when gaming at 1080 p and easy access
Bay for component upgrades all secured
with only one single screw the price for
all this starts at $799 and scales up
easily depending on whatever level of
additional components or performance
improvements you'd like so there's that
1050 TI upgrade option 4K panel upgrade
option supports up to 32 GB of RAM and
it is all yeah for $7.99 yeah it's a
beastful little little here quite nice
did you get into PC gaming yes but not
un till last year actually yeah yeah I
was all console all the time and then
last year I got into PC gaming and I I'm
so glad I did I actually I think I enjoy
it more it depends on it depends on like
what I'm playing but yeah for Shooters
absolutely takes a little commitment
definitely more commitment than uh the
other games but like I'm playing
OverWatch exclusively on PC I was
playing Killing Floor 2 exclusively on
PC how was your transition to mouse and
keyboard it was rough sucks yeah I
sucked so bad at the beginning but now I
I get it now and I'm pretty decent I
kill FL and still okay at OverWatch I'm
going to die there's no way I'm going to
work here yeah this is rough it's saying
to take
cover oh boy don't really give you too
much cover though not really there's
nothing there's nowhere to
go
did you get into Counter Strike at all
no no I missed that whole thing but my
brother used to play so I filar with all
the hype around it and how popular it
was it's tough game I
bet down to try it now
though um so I think I'm supposed to
shoot some kind of a big barrel
probably oh no this guy shoots torpedoes
yeah
torpedo locked on TST shoot
it that's
hard nothing think is going fasty and
we're hanging out in the chat on YouTube
and twitch so if you have any questions
while Hut is under pressure here let us
know and I'll relay those questions for
him we're over on gamespot's YouTube and
twitch but we're also streaming on
Hutch's twitch channel so hello to
everyone there I have a question for you
that I'm sure a lot of people in the
chat probably have asked themselves at
one point but what what is it what give
me your overall um perspective of
working in the games industry like
what's your 9 to5 like oh gez it's
different every single day like you're
focusing on one to two to three games at
a time um you're constantly trying to
come up with fun things to do with those
games and fun things to feature about
those games um yeah it's like constantly
just thinking of ideas and executing on
them and like a lot of production lot of
video production um I think about social
a lot I used to produce um the Snapchat
channel for IGN so I had to think about
fun ways to just present things on
different platforms all the social media
platforms but yeah Snapchat was
interesting to produce for oh no but it
was also
very limiting because it was 10 seconds
and vertical video so I I still haven't
made a Snapchat yet so it's okay you can
do the same thing on Instagram stories
now so you don't even need it really
anymore getting huge though they're
getting real big they've even got like a
legit news division now too which is
interesting yep that's uh what I made
the IGN s chat 4 for their Discover
Channel they have like 20 channels on
there oh
no torpedo destroy this looks
tough um some of these actually are
pretty tough I'm not I'm not even
playing the
difficult second friction glider
incoming no [__] if you could give one
piece of advice to someone who's
watching this right
now about this game no no no like hoping
to get into the games industry what
would you uh what would you say make
stuff right now making stuff start
making stuff and keep doing that that's
a good advice make your own things make
your own channel learn how to build your
channel learn how to edit yeah learn how
to edit learn how to capture gameplay
learn how to edit work on your voice
just be as many different roles as you
can be a oneman band that's the that's
one thing that I still struggle with is
projecting when you when you're doing
these sort of things cuz it like I kind
of naturally default to like a Casey
Affleck kind of a voice you know where
it's kind of I kind of hear that I can
hear that yeah but that was the one
thing that I had the the most problems
with come
on I Didn't Do It Again did I no we're
good
nice but yeah projecting is projecting
tough yeah well I mean it's not tough
but it's it's tough to like retrain
yourself
mhm but is a minute if that
reinforcements all right what yeah what
are we what are we doing train going
it's a bit difficult to manage it oh
here we
go trying to shoot a barrel over there
but yeah oh there it is
are get one
person I don't know I couldn't even
see my chat is used to much more
toxicity I play I play uh I play games
with my pals we're not very nice to each
other oh man so I think we're supposed
to start yelling at each other here but
I'm not playing you can just pretend
it's fine I to just criticize you even
though I'm not playing that seems wrong
that just seems wrong I would have done
that better and faster
h no don't do that yeah you're right
it's not your strong suit I really
wouldn't have let's back that up let's
walk it up a little
bit cheeks bones that could be broken
I'm pretty nice I don't usually ever get
on the mic when I'm playing
games oh you don't not really this thing
is Holding On by an ass
hair so what game are you looking
forward to this year stdy enough we're
about to find out um God damn it can you
help me out like what's what's what's
what's what's coming out what's left
yeah do you play Nintendo at all um not
really man you know what I used to be
exclusively Nintendo I was it was
Nintendo 64 then I got a GameCube and
then I got a
Wii but I haven't played Nintendo in a
while I had a Wii U and I kind any
interest in the switch um yeah I do yeah
I can't you can't really find them right
now but uh yeah and they just
discontinued the NES classic edition
yesterday did you hear that what what
was that in the first place it's just
the small tiny little NES that you can
play like 30 games on and why did they
discontinue that cuz there was too much
demand they can't keep up with it
something like that I that seems like
kind of sucks that seems like kind of a
[__] excuse too many people want
this so we're just not going to sell it
anymore really sad about it I have to
say I didn't go to business school or
anything but that seems that seems
counterintuitive to me
yeah let us know in the chat what games
you're looking forward to this year
what I mean what other what other games
are coming out well I'm I'm hyped for if
we get a new Marvel vs Capcom this year
and we're supposed to infinite is
supposed to happen I'm stoked for that
infinite yeah Marvel vers Campa Marv C
and then um do you think they'll
announce um a new Bioshock at E3 cuz
they said they were working on it just
like last year didn't they who can tell
I don't know I would love if they if
they announc a new Bioshock like I
understand it's not going to be the same
team but I still love that series man
mhm that's
great uh what what what else is let's
see what else am I looking forward to
well I want to play the new Mario game
but then I'd have to get a switch I
don't have one yet are they going to
announce a new
Skyrim no they're putting on switch
though it's not the new it's not a new
one they're going to but when it's on
switch it'll be like I think it'll they
they downgraded it right cuz like if you
want to play it portably play it port I
don't think you have to play portably
but if you want to they they really
degrade the the graphics or something I
don't know i' played I've played enough
Skyrim I don't need to play it
again yeah I do want to play Sonic Mania
I hope that's coming out this year
someone just mentioned the new Sonic
game looks cool Sonic Mania yeah what's
what is that I haven't even heard of
that Sonic the Hedgehog if you are
familiar with my friend Sonic yes the
have delivered me a spectacular it's
very uh Classic Sonic that's what
excites me about it okay all right Sonic
oh Outlast 2 yeah that is coming out
soon that's a that's a horror surviv I'm
going to get real scared did you play
the most recent Resident
Evil no I watch I watched some friends
play it on on their streams it looks
pretty good though
yeah on Twitch someone said Hut on
Gamespot WTF what did this happen today
he's just a special guest hanging out
today very special yeah we like having
special guests this is a big deal for
you guys to have me this is a huge deal
I was just like hold on to your butts
everyone the office was like and you
were like yeah yeah I know I know
right someone's bringing up Battlefield
one did you
play um no I'm not I can't I'm not I
can't like I respect Battlefield I
respect Battlefield that's a great
answer
like I respect Battlefield I do and
maybe if I got more invested in on on PC
cuz like most of my experience was on
consoles which is I don't think that's
the way you're supposed to play that
game um but yeah I don't know maybe
that's something I'll get into like
during the dry spell of Summer Des 2 in
September yeah there you go that's
probably what for I'm definitely looking
forward to that more than any here
is damn that's
that's so
weird oh great kicking things is
probably my favorite thing about this
game kicking things as duke nuk them is
my favorite thing about this game I
think we're supposed to
escape get out of here let us know in
the chat if you want to see any kind of
creative kills like what do you what
would you like to see us do in this game
we'll try to get that done the bar nice
and well set the bar nice and
well as long as you don't expect too
much from me I won't disappoint you oh
boy I don't know where I'm going behind
us do I jump over
here you know I've watched Cosmos on
Netflix about three times really yeah I
can watch that show anytime good stuff
just felt like saying that out loud for
some what other shows are you watching
or have you watched
recently I I can always watch parks and
wreck I love parks and wreck a fantastic
I never watched it until this this last
year I don't know if this will make
people mad but I like I think parks and
Rex as a whole is better than the office
I agree right right I me they're far
more consistent seasons of Parkson wck
than there are of the office the office
has maybe three and a
half Good Seasons but Parkson wck as a
whole so much better yeah Ron Swanson
quickly became one of my characters in
show he was also real good in um Fargo
season 2 did you watch that I watched a
bit i' I'm only six episodes in but I
need to catch up but you don't really
need to catch up to watch season 3 but I
feel like I want to uh well then I think
it would be a good idea CU because they
they find ways to tie tie the seasons
together right but season one was
fantastic oh that's great that's a good
show yeah the Season 3 starting next
week now UK office or us office office
um like there's so much us office and
there's so little UK office so I don't
know if it's a really fair comparison
but I do they had two or two seasons or
three seasons of the UK version like
like two I think two or three and then
they had a Christmas special too that
was like an hour long not much and then
there was just like a million us Seasons
like s too many oh Ricky D is fantastic
in that show though
MH oh someone brought up Legion he said
Legion is the best thing I've ever seen
in my life I've only seen one episode
really good it's stunning it's just I
love the way it's directed I love the
visuals for it it's very very creative I
just checked out into the Badlands for
the first time I haven't seen that oh my
God the action in it is is uh pretty
brutal yeah it's AMC so they kind of get
away with a little bit more oh what is
this yes they do fire bucket said isn't
Fargo a movie yes it is a movie and now
it's also a TV series unlock rearm
access purchase access soon let's just
do it oh there we go okay I get it I'm
not going to do
that I think I just muted it I
did Dre Maximus on Twitch said into the
bad lands is epic oh it's great I'll
take your word for it guys that's great
cool you know it's show that I wanted to
get into but I just couldn't was better
better fall I never got into it either
but I keep hearing that it's really
good I got through about like five or
six episodes of the first season and I
was like I like this but it's just it's
not bad that makes me upset right makes
me more sad than anything all right here
we
go
nice so if you're just tuning in we're
playing Bullet Storm full clip Edition
on the Inspiron
157,000 thanks to our friends at Dell
gaming and we're hanging out with hutch
so if you have any questions let us know
on gam spots YouTube or twitch and I can
relay those to him we're playing for
roughly another half hour hour we have a
half hour left 28 minutes in our stream
oh we're playing till 12:30 12:30 my
budd's going to be so pissed oh no you
think it was 12 I told him noon oh it's
all right you can wait listen we're
going to have to cut this stream off
right understand it's sponsored or
anything but I got food to eat so
uh this guy doesn't like being all right
you know
what how many of those um oh I haven't
even used
those my charge shot I'm going to skin
you alive that must be one of those 12
what do you think that charge
shot it's good it's good good charge
shot good charge
shot solid solid it's very assass
charges pretty pretty aggressively
shoots that's a good slide very
nice
um that's my favorite like combination
like doing the energy leash and shooting
right in the head getting that head shot
yeah oh look at
you um what what are some other shows
that you got into recently uh let's see
yeah so I'm starting on Legion um I'm
watching a lot of Bates Motel cuz it's
almost over there's two episodes left so
I'm watching that a lot I I haven't I
haven't touched that one yet yeah it's a
based off the psycho yeah and also the
flash but I've kind of fell off on that
Agents of Shield I'm still watching
didn't didn't Agents of Shield start off
real bad and then it got good yep I
always recommend if you are getting into
Agents of Shield to kind of do other
things while you're watching the first
nine 10 episodes because it doesn't like
really find its ground and become really
good until it ties in with Captain
America Winter Soldier like episod 10
how is Agent Coulson alive I don't
understand that gets explained you want
to for me no no you have to watch Agents
of Shield cuz then that's a spoiler for
people that haven't seen show yet but
yeah he's he's still alive
clearly a sense who really ever dies in
comic book movies and shows that's what
I worry about with Doctor Strange right
that they're just going to anytime
someone dies like turn the clock back
the biggest problem I have with the
Marvel movies right now is like nobody
dies like I really wanted to kill off
Tony or uh or uh or cap in in Civil War
I was like man if they do that that'd be
great it's like part of the reason why
Game of Thrones is so great is cuz
anyone can die yeah I mean I understand
they're not trying to be Game of Thrones
understand oh Game of Thrones there we
go that's a show I'm waiting for but
it's not till mid July how many months
is that is that three months
now yeah it's supposed to be it's
supposed to be in the spring but because
they had to like schedule it around
shooting winter shoots now yeah I I
thought the rumor last year was that it
wasn't gon to come out until literally
this winter or something like that may
yeah luckily it's mid July we have to
wait that long did you get a chance to
watch Westworld yes I was super into
Westworld and we did recap videos here
at Gamespot about every single episode
and that was so much fun yeah I was a
huge fan of that show but that's not
coming back till 2018 yeah that really
bummed me out when I heard that God that
was so good the soundtrack's Great too
you can okay I think I'm stuck I love
all the piano covers of random genres of
songs that they
do so I'm stuck uh oh are we stuck yeah
what is happening I don't know can I
restart the checkpoint
CRA you got
stuck I do not take responsibility it's
the game the game did oh yeah cable 2 is
coming out I'm sorry Deadpool so psyched
about casting Josh BR J yeah yeah I
think it's perfect I thought Michael
Shannon was he was rumored for that too
and I thought he would have been he's
great in everything uh but
yeah I think Deadpool is one of those
movies that like it I think it's good
for like one viewing it doesn't it
doesn't really strike me as one of the
movies that you can watch over and over
again uh but it's good good come on
another party for you the rumor was that
Ryan uh Ryan Reynolds leaked that
remember that test footage that got
leaked
the rumor was that he leaked that
himself yeah I think
toate that was the rumor I I believe
it oh did that get confirmed I don't
know
yeah but everyone seemed like they
believed it this isn't
good no I didn't mean to do that people
are talking about the flash yeah I still
watch The Flash it's fun it's better
than Arrow that's just a fact I tried
watching it uh Arrow first two seasons
were very good and then I it just fell
off so currently current arrow is not as
good as current
flash did they say um I think they said
they were but are they bringing in uh
the Netflix characters for Infinity War
uh TBD I I don't know but they're doing
the Defenders but I I'd imagine they'd
have some kind of Cameo what did you
think of uh Iron Fist did you watch it I
didn't watch it no that's that's the one
Netflix Marvel series that I had no
interest in I was just like dude you
should have just introduced him in
Defenders like I don't think he needed
his own show like I saw clips from it
and I was just not feeling it you know
some some of the some of the way that
they shot the action scenes were a
little frenetic too frenetic uh like
that there did you see that clip that
was circulating on Twitter where the um
it was like a minute and a half action
scene but it had like 90 Cuts or
something like that oh jez so it was
really hard to hard to watch hard to
follow yeah it's definitely the weakest
of all the the Netflix Marvel characters
uh so far but I didn't think it was
terrible I would give it like a 6.5 all
right maybe seems fair we're going to
use one of those arbitrary numbers seems
fair yeah I like uh Daredevil season one
I like Jessica
Jones Luke Cage was good for like the
first half oh you didn't like the way I
I thought it was better the second half
really
yeah and I'm kind of a big deal so I'm
starting to you guys are oh I didn't
mean to shoot
you you got to do this when you drw
yep oh you get bonus points for that all
right that's clever that's clever I like
it Duke Nukem is an action hero in his
own right do you have any favorite
action heroes
movies I mean like growing up Ninja
Turtles were like a h huge part of my
childhood yeah dude love the turtles it
was like a fatherson bonding bonding
experience he would take me to all the
new movies
um yeah the rock I mean Arnold
Schwarzenegger was like you know True
Lies I don't know if I'm answering what
was your question gu action heroes no
you are you are answering yeah you
saying Arnold you saying the rock yeah
yeah I was always big X-Men fan too
Logan was Logan's fav movie yeah Logan's
up there for me as well that was a
perfect movie and just a good movie in
general it really like I like that they
kind of they you know they really
stepped out of what wolverine had
traditionally been in the Cinematic
Universe and I thought that that was I
mean why not I mean they they had
already kind of screwed up the time
timeline that timeline is all over the
place for Wolverine oh man it's so bad
just X-Men in general
yeah yeah I don't think they know what
they're doing over
there we've got a about 20 minutes left
in the Stream we're playing bold storm
full clip Edition we're hanging out on
YouTube and twitch if you want to get
your questions in hang out with us
people are talking about their favorite
shows right now talking about cable and
Deadpool which we're very psyched about
someone's talking about Jessica Jones on
YouTube um it it does kind
of it does kind of throw me off a little
bit when people agree to do a character
in multiple uh comic book movies so Josh
broland being both Thanos and cable yeah
and then you also
like Fox Marvel so it's kind of
separated but still two Marvel
characters yeah and then it Michael B
Jordan is another one he was in
Fantastic 4 and I think he's I think
he's going to be in a Black Panther cast
him for that he is um I'm psyed for that
too I think that'll be good oh yeah
that'll be great I really like his
introduction in uh Civil War they got
the guy I can't remember his name maybe
you do but it's the guy cougler I think
is his last name is he's the one that he
directed uh Creed M which was great that
was a good movie yeah unexpectedly
great let us know your favorite action
heroes on the chat someone said John
Wick on YouTube yep John Wick was fun
yeah the second one was it was it was
such a pure sequel to the first it was
just like straight accurate directly
connected to the first one it's like I
feel like you did have to watch the
first one to watch the second
one oh there's a charge shot for this
too
the cool amount of money should we look
at the so I guess the kills the special
kills that we can get oh yeah I can do
that do that so if you're tuning in late
it gives you extra points for doing
these creative
kills we've checked some of those off it
seems like it'd be pretty hard Kill An
Enemy by shooting in the well I guess
you can just them shoot an enemy in the
balls uh slide an enemy and shoot him to
death midair and kick or shoot his head
head off and then this is the one that
we just unlocked I think there's one
over here too yeah
nice all right so let me see what this
one is
like Liz James said since touch is there
will be he CH will he Challenge chassity
and Just Dance do you play Just
[Laughter]
Dance no I don't I prefer not to
dance I actually like for a long time I
had this there there's a clinical term
for it maybe someone in the CH can do
some Googling but I had a legit like
phobia of Dancing Yeah I see that as a
thing that could totally be a thing it
really made me
uncomfortable uh I was at a wedding
party one time and they didn't tell me
that you had to dance they that I had to
dance dancing not only did you have have
to dance you had to like walk out into
the crowd and just find someone to dance
with it was a horrible experience what
that's no you should plan that a little
bit though that's not nice to do to your
friend
well he didn't know but I had this rare
psychological disorder that that made me
uh terrified of dancing but then but
then like recently more recently it's
actually been pretty okay
yeah you ever go to like uh EDM shows or
anything like that yeah not really I I
stay in most of the time kind of a
homebody you just Just Dance a lot in
your home or what oh yeah no like House
parties and stuff like hanging out with
friends [__]
oh oh is this a
boss
okay toast manx said I can relate to
that dancing phobia there it's the worst
it's the worst I bet when you're uh tall
and lanky generally uncoordinated you're
expected to carry a rhythm n whoa what
is this know what I
did someone on YouTube said it's
chorophobia fear of
dancing chobia r o okay all right like
choreography okay that makes that makes
sense take your word for it look it up
later yeah no it
oh all
[Applause]
right oh God it's terrible let me try
that
again how do I oh there we go oh my God
they're everywhere they are everywhere
it's okay you can take them up kick them
kick them if they get too close did it
like
it we have about 15 minutes left in the
Stream so get your last minute questions
in and we will ask them to Hutch or to
me to both of us talk about what you're
afraid of Hut is afraid of dancing I'm
afraid of spiders airplanes that's
another thing too oh yeah I I don't like
flying at all I really don't like it
when you have to do you like try to KN
yourself out and go to sleep um how do
you play I mean I just bite the bull but
but the whole time that I'm flying I'm
I'm convinced in my mind that the plane
could just go down at any moment scary
to to me it doesn't really register that
it's like a one in a million like
literally I lo I looked it up it's like
a one in a million shot sa way to travel
you were too to know what definitely way
safer than a car I had a bad experience
though just just just recently yeah
there was there was some wind shear as
we were landing and the plane tilted so
like the the wing could have SM on oh no
it's terrible yeah he had to pull back
up and this is going into Vegas have you
ever flown into Vegas you know it's just
just the worst turbulence cuz it's
surrounded by all those mountains and
everything yeah it was terrifying so we
had to charge we had to charge back up
through the turbulence and people were
like people were like uh praying and
screaming it was like that level oh my
wow man it scar scared the living [__]
out of me no it's all right it's not
your fault I get it
ooh um but yeah no it's be bees uh
flying and dancing but I would say my
top three fears in life yeah bees are
pretty scary man they're terrifying yeah
there was a bee in my car once when I
was driving I had to pull over and I got
out of the car the worst is when they're
like all the windows get in your shoe
and you don't real oh no no oh that'd be
awful I don't even the Aquarius 79 on
YouTube said what do you guys think of
True Detective I love season 1 season 1
was fantastic television don't sleep on
season 2 it's season was all right but
it's no season one you have to agree
with that like season one yeah I agree
with that incredible yeah I agree I'm
going to agree with you on that one but
but uh the like the problem with season
2 was that it was like really
complicated it was comp the plot was
just physically impossible to follow
yeah it's hard to follow and you fail to
because of that you fail to care about
any of the characters yeah like you
don't care what happens to them at all
if you go back and watch it a second
time like and use um use some kind like
a website or or something like that to
help you follow then I think you might
enjoy it like I even enjoyed uh Vince V
the second time I watched it and the
first time I watched I'm like I'm just
not buying him as I wasn't that's how I
felt I wasn't really buying him in that
role no that's good
stuff and I usually love Rachel McAdams
and everything and I I still liked her
there but I failed to care about her
character as well oh I actually I loved
her in that I thought um what's his name
was the best Colin frell col frell was
the best one but but uh I didn't think
she was too bad in that she always does
a good job but I think it was just it
wasn't a great character you're right
though season one is it's real real
tough act to follow I really came around
on uh MCC because of that because of
True Detective season one he um he
recently came out and said that he'd be
he's open to doing another season if the
rider comes up with something Nick poano
his name is pick uh something yeah poano
I think I don't know what but
uh
um but yeah I would I would lose my mind
if they announced the new season with
him in it yeah he
um what's his name uh he I think the
right or left to do some kind of a show
for Showtime if I'm not mistaken the the
big thing was that the director had left
right I thought I think it was the
writer writer yeah the but the
showrunner writer was the one that
stayed on for season two did he leave
now I don't remember after season two
yeah I think I think he signs to some
show to to write some show for Showtime
maybe I'm not sure but but it just
recently was in the in the news that you
might come back and revisit that series
get ready Deadwood is another yeah
someone mentioned Deadwood on the
YouTube chat yeah dead they they've been
talking about doing a movie to wrap up
that whole St storyline for a while do
you think they still could well I read
an article like I want to say probably
about 5 months ago that that said that
it they do have plans to do that they're
just I don't know what second but
they've been talking about this for like
years literally so I don't know it's a
great show you guys haven't watched that
yet you know what's fun about that show
is like you feel like you have to learn
a new a new language like the first
couple episodes cuz they speak kind of
very Shakespearean kind of old school
English and uh it's it's literally hard
to understand what the hell they're
talking about around that yeah but after
like a couple episodes you kind of feel
like you're learning the language so
it's fun it's a real fun show all right
so while we've got about 10 minutes left
in the Stream let's see what kind of
kills we can get with 10 minutes left
what do you think as I
die you're going to get another
chance some people talking about Crash
Bandicoot in the chat they're hyped for
the new crash
Trilogy coming out this year mean I saw
that at uh pack meanwhile in my chat
yeah what' they say just oh boy I'm not
gonna read
that but hello you're a Rowdy bunch
[Laughter]
let's see what kind of creative kills we
can get with the last 10 minutes left in
the game I'm just going to do
this terrible get more points creative
kills
FY real anti
guys I kicked him against I think we got
graffi points graffiti
points can you throw someone into that
fan kick them into the fan to the fan
that fan that's oh like right in front
of him oh well that fan was back
there I'm sorry I'm fing that's okay I'm
just going to check you for a second are
you talking about oh that okay all right
tur there's nobody left
oh there go oh I think I just
H BL nice blind all
right uh where's another is there a
spiky Plan Focus on the heavy
gun B
executed no it's
close where oh okay that should be fun
should be fun yep let's use some of
these lav
wires kick up yeah
shocker another one another one y yep
yep
good I don't understand okay there we
go
any fun plans for the weekend uh sleep
it's been a busy week did a lot this
week so I'm looking forward to sleeping
it's always fun mhm she returned their
you let yourself sleep in on the weekend
yes
absolutely not disturb on my phone
usually like depends on how late I
stayed up the night before playing video
games like so if I'm staying up till two
playing myself hours after difficult to
convince her to Aid our evacuation if
she recognizes no later than us I'm not
going to tell you my
[Laughter]
answer sometimes 12 why am I kicking
this all right there you go because of
that yeah environmental
kill
my all right so with the seven minutes
we have left let us know what kind of
kills you'd like to see or what other
questions you have left for us while
we're still here for the next few
minutes on Twitch and YouTube on games
spots twitch and
YouTube I'll make no
promises do the best I can
M I think you're dead but let's just do
that
just that killed
you at worst that broke your
back at worst guns du
[__]
yeah go [__] yourself you [__] piles
give Chase I
will mouth on
themick Dell if you're watching this is
not my
fault I did not green like
this
hello yo these things suck man I
can't
oh those things are brutal that's rough
oh that is
rough but we will try one more time and
then we'll show off the inspra 157,000
one last time before we say goodbye to
the good people on all of our streams I
like that second to
last so much changes huh
friendzone hey identify yourself or I
will open fire Duke [__] Nukem
remember it for later baby
nuk yeah go [__] yourself you [__] PS
give Chase I will kill your dicks what
does that even
mean a oh did I mess this
up
go oh question all on YouTube which PS3
or Xbox 360 games do you guys want
remastered um they already remastered
Bioshock right
nouni I like nuni a lot um oh Deadly
Premonition but I just love that game
have you heard of it no I love is it
like a horror game or something it's
it's Twin Peaks the game I never watched
Twin Peak so I'm guessing you're okay
all right I love Twin Peaks I I love I
gather you're excited for the I'm so
excited that's coming out May 21st I'm
really excited to watch more Twin
Peaks here we
go oh I'm out of all right
is that a guy that I'm aiming at right
there no oh
nope
uh oh there you
are Enlightenment very
nice um if you had if you had to sell me
on Twin Peaks in like a couple sentences
how would you how would you uh um Twin
Peaks is the most surreal TV like TV
experience I've ever had where after I
watch it I kind of question reality a
little bit really yeah it's fun it's fun
but it's very immersive like it starts
it's like the elevator pitch is that it
starts off as a standard procedural like
crime drama who done it the girl got
killed but then it just devolves into
something so weird like there's so much
interesting stuff going on very or David
Fincher David Lynch yeah okay David
Lynch did it mhm yeah and he's coming
back to do the
yeah no worries I got him he's um have
you seen any of his films yeah a couple
he's kind of an interesting director huh
very yeah interesting is is the word for
it not really light viewing kind of like
like what you said that's a kind of yeah
his stuff is kind of stuff where you
watching then question the nature of
reality that's yes so you feel the same
way watching te PE but it's it's also
part like soap opera and then part like
weird sci-fi fantasy-esque
quest in reality type of thing get down
with that
yeah
get TR to get one more good kill before
we wrap up our stream we got three
minutes left nice that was good
hello look the boss one of our mods Ben
is a big fan of Deadly Premonition he
was very happy I mentioned it and people
are like that's not a good game oh
that's
good I'm not saying it's a good game I'm
saying I I like
it I enjoy it cuz I love Twin Peaks and
I just want to playn Peaks the
game this game is kind of tough man even
on normal difficulty I'm kind of
struggling this game is tough but it's
fun Beautiful Joe beautiful Jo remas
that was such a great game that was so
good man good call dude good
call two minutes left so let's get a
couple more kills and then we're going
to cut to the b roll one more time and
say goodbye to the good folks on our
streams that was good no I'm going to
die oh oh oh no bye oh no I totly
expected to die though
wow NOP
[Applause]
stop all right let's have that be our
last kill heav you and on a high note so
let's cut to that b roll one more time
thanks for watching we've been playing
on the Inspiron
157,000 one last look at it so thanks to
our friends at Dell gaming for providing
this for us it's part of Dell's new
gaming lineup and they have learned from
Alienware and their XPS lineup and so
they've implemented that into this
redesigned the hinge so that it's
stronger and Stor for you can close it
and open it like 20,000 times and it's
still good and improved keyboard with
testing for keys to 10 million
keystrokes and touchpad buttons 1
million times with no failure new dual
fan cooling system featuring oversized
fans with rear exhaust to ensure optimal
temperatures even the copper fins are
painted to match the rest of the trim
very nice GTX 1050 and 1050i GPU options
offer some of the most impressive
performance per dollar when gaming at
1080p easy access Bay for component
upgrades all secured with only one
single screw and the price for all of
this starts at
$799 and scales up easily depending on
whatever level of additional components
or performance improvements you'd like
so look into that and that's all for
today uh thank you for Jo or Oz through
that whole thing thank you very much so
where can they find you on Twitch and on
Twitter anything on on Twitter and
twitch I'm sorry on on um on Twitch and
on YouTube it's just
youtube.com Hutch twitch.tv Hut and on
Twitter it's zag gotouch if you just
search Hutch you should be able to find
it thanks for having me on appreciate
thank you for playing us thank you for
playing and doing all those awesome
kills take care everyone thanks for
joining us and thanks to Dell gaming
[Music]
bye